[Music]
as reality gets Dumber return to the
franchise that's always been stupid did
you hear me with the helicopter back
there and wrap yourself in a big warm
blanket
until deep fake Paul Walker down shifts
from Heaven to save the day in the next
one calling it now fast X
gear up for a Back to Basics fast film
Cars cakes and killing Brazilians
or really anyone who speaks Portuguese
with everything you want from a fast and
or Furious movie except for an ending
it's three acts in any story are you
guys confirming right now that we're
getting a
yeah they're gonna drag this baby out as
long as possible cause Michelle
Rodriguez does not want to make the
assignment too
the family who loves to drink and drive
together is back minus director Justin
Lin who quit rather than take one more
script note from Vin Diesel uh excuse me
have you met your dad
okay that's a pretty big show as always
they're led by Dom Toretto whose Arc
from man to talking Gravel Pit is almost
complete I only care about protecting
the people that I love how it feels like
all the hangers have been cut
litty who continues to have less
chemistry with her husband than Helen
Mirren for choosing a lonely way in my
darling Roman who keeps one child
support payment strapped to him at all
times tej the comic relief whose punch
lines wouldn't make it into the worst
ludicrous song only thing you know about
Romans Roman noodles Ramsay does
machines I I don't know oh that's right
I know stuff now and Fan Favorite Han
who this time goes on an acid trip and
lasts all of 30 seconds yep we've gone
from Justice for Han to just this for
Han you love The Rock back in his
franchise Viagra days now Make Way for
Jason Momoa as franchise ammo nitrate
poppers I'm Dante I'm Shantae as we
flash back to the fifth and still best
movie where I guess he's had a little
work done since then to meet Dante a
villain who burst under the scene and
loosens up these tight buttholes all
right dorks what are we blowing up
injecting some fun back into the fast
charge with his wild combo of sexy Jesus
Paulie Shores Pinocchio here we go let's
go to vote
and tons of Joker stuff a million
dollars for whoever can be
how about we all just start shooting
each other and see what happens that's
so cool did you know
listen to me
Bob pay attention careful this is how
you get a dead pig in the mail from
Jared Leto you want to kill them never
accept death and suffering is owed oh
I'm not gonna kill you I'm just gonna
hurt you really
really
bad Dante he's got an evil plan to make
Dom suffer by killing his son and now I
know where to find your son but first he
has to hire part of Dom's crew for a
fake mission to frame them as terrorists
Dominic Toretto take out Dom's rival by
kidnapping 11 of her henchman's loved
ones
and then it's a simple matter of luring
dumb to Brazil
setting up an art installation full of
production steals from previous fast
movies hoping Dom's contact brings the
God's eye surveillance McGuffin to their
Meetup ambushing their Caravan to steal
it I brought you back to where we first
met using God's eye to find Dom's son
luring down to a dam he's rigged a blow
with remote controlled tanker trucks
after he shot down an airplane full of
Dom's family right as they arrive at the
exact moment so Dom can see it for
himself it's like they say revenge is a
dish best serve at the end of a 30
course meal after everyone is
disgustingly full did you really think
it was going to be that easy that was
easy while Dante is actually a really
good bad guy all the bad guys turned
good are still hanging around like Ames
a vanilla gorilla who checks every fnf
Trope in his debut changing sides
cancels mine first appearing to die
and previously playing Aquaman that's a
new one Cypher who pulls up in a
DeLorean so fast 11 time travel
confirmed the shawls for one imperial
micro unit of screen time and Jacob
Toretto as they wisely let John Cena
activate dork mode and act like a
Make-a-Wish for the world's greatest
Uncle enjoy the ride little B
wee isn't this a fun road trip you
learned about 90s music and you got your
first confirmed kills
welcome to the family Little Bee
barbecues every Sunday therapy never
so strap in for the most grown happy
action movie since Michael Bay figured
out how to fly one under a car
[Music]
where the physics may not make any sense
four
[Music]
but the gravity of these movies somehow
keeps us coming back for more it's like
a cult with cars even Wonder Woman in
the Rock can't escape their pool the
devil is coming for you that post fast
life humbles you huh enough champagne
to fill the Nile life outside fast ties
is rough then knows what I'm talking
about quick like a turtle lie on your
back
story yep you guessed it more car puns
I'm root Ready set go car Drogo Cash for
Clunkers American Muscle Fury Roadster
gone and 60 stathams reliable handling
get Jack get Jack you lift cars up with
that ramming speed Captain Carville
police maker Street Davidson drag queen
e West ride story and one eight seven
seven cars for kids
k-a-r-s cars for kids car Wars episode
10 Return of the Jedi
I'm glad they're finally getting the
band back together for the next one just
please don't literally get the band back
together
[Applause]
it's about drive it's about power we
stay hungry we devour imagine there's no
hell heaven Dom toretto's life is
ridiculous and because we love wasting
smart people's time we made a physicist
psychologist and lawyer analyze his
adventures to see just how dumb they are
click the Box on the right to watch now
you don't need Epic trailer voice when
you have family Dove man oh yeah my name
is epic voice guy five years ago I was
stranded on an island with nothing but
recording equipment like a fine wine I'm
aging gracefully thank you